and the suspense is killing me it is
indeed a tails chris you get the first
pick well look chris what we have phil
sims in super bowl no i know what it's
going to be it's going to be jeff
hosteller in super bowl 25. he was
horrible if phil sims played in that
game they would have won by 30 no no uh
jeff hosteller played very well in that
game of course okay i'm gonna go with
shaving cream in his cleats i'm gonna go
right off the bat and this hurts me to
say okay because i really like this guy
and he was a teammate of mine at one
point but this was one of the worst
performances i've seen and it's not only
because of this player the defense he
played was amazing but i'm going to go
with kerry collins in super bowl 34
the one against the great baltimore
ravens defense kerry collins that day
was 15 for 39 112 yards and four
interceptions now we know that was a
special defense but that was a rough day
in a super bowl where you know again the
giants were not the better team the
giants came out and this doesn't all go
on kerry collins either i feel like they
came out thinking they were going to
throw the ball all over the lot just
like they did against your minnesota
vikings in the nfc championship that
year but they won 41 to nothing and
we're a little bit maybe arrogant in
their approach to just say oh we don't
care we can throw it and do move the
ball against anybody and obviously they
should have played a different style of
game that day trying to throw the ball
too much ray lewis mvp uh but carrie
collins certainly struggled that day
against uh one of the greatest defenses
we've ever seen
well first of all we have a
disqualification right out of the gates
because
kerry collins did not play in super bowl
34. he played in super bowl thirty-five
oh i was one thirty right right yeah
yeah hey hey no you you that's it it's
over you're done
your first pick you won the toss you get
the first pick and you screw up the
number i know roman numerals are
difficult to discern but it was 35 all
right i'm gonna go two super bowls
further and i thought you were going in
this direction because i think by far
the worst performance of any quarterback
in any super bowl came from the guy that
your former coach john gruden turned
into an mvp but then he got a chance to
face him in super bowl 37 he knew all
the calls all the audibles he john
gruden actually jumped in and played
scout team quarterback that's right so
they could hear how rich gannon did his
cadence the end result not one not two
not three five interceptions for rich
gannon three of them were returned for
touchdowns dwight smith should have been
the mvp of that game but again they vote
on the mvp
with five minutes left if they would
have waited until the end dwight smith
who had two pick sixes in that game
would have been the mvp should have been
the mvp the lvp rich gannon worst
performance ever for any quarterback in
the super bowl with those five
interceptions yeah that was uh
definitely a tough day at the office for
rich king i still just don't even
understand like what the hell the
oakland raiders were thinking in that
matchup i mean did they really hey
speaking of games being thrown you know
what tim brown said a few years ago what
he said bill callahan threw it bill
callahan threw the game for his friend
john gruden i mean it's one of the more
insane things really in the history of
football the guy who invented your
offense and gave this team all their
checks and the oakland raiders when john
gruden was coaching that team they go
the next year and have to play that guy
on the super bowl
and they don't change their checks or
anything about it and just stay status
quo did they really think john gruden
wasn't gonna tell warren sapp and simeon
rice and dwight smith and rondae barber
and derek brooks what the hell the
checks were like that is one of the
all-time like my brain blows up emoji of
ever in the history of the sport i don't
understand what the hell they talk about
self-scouting yourself yeah self-scout
yourself extra when the damn team your
offense is put in by the other team's
head coach i will never understand that
all right i'm gonna take a um
i'm gonna i know you might go a little
old school so i'm staying a little bit
more recent for now i'm gonna go with a
winning
super bowl quarterback okay i'm gonna go
with big ben roethlisberger okay and
super bowl what was that super bowl 40.
i'm just calling these by my top of my
head that's why i keep messing them up
super bowl 40 though in my lifetime i i
think that that was one of the worst
performances i saw out of the
quarterback position crazy that they got
the win shows you it's a team sport but
big ben that day nine for 29 for 21 123
yards and two interceptions and tons of
errant passes and errant throws if
you're watching on tv you see a wobbler
that he throws up at the jump ball that
gets intercepted they were getting close
to scoring on another opportunity and he
threw a ball that was almost a pick six
he was all over the place that day he
was flustered he did not play well the
best throw of the day by a pittsburgh
steeler was by antoine randall l in the
touchdown pass he threw on the reverse
pass um to heinz ward but that was uh
pretty pitiful pretty pitiful by big ben
roethlisberger did have a rushing
touchdown that day but it was a
controversial one that should have been
overturned on replay review and it
wasn't or it or it wasn't rule to touch
it on the field it was on replay
whatever it was they screwed it up it
didn't look like a touchdown but he did
have that going for him all right i am
going to go old school i'm going to go
back to super bowl 12 and i remember the
1977 season very vividly it was the
orange crush year that was a year that
the denver broncos emerged as a power
and they toppled the raiders and they
got to the super bowl and they faced the
cowboys in the super dome and craig
morton the starting quarterback for the
denver broncos had four completions
and four interceptions a passer rating
of zero 0.0
in the super bowl the cowboys won 27 to
10 but it felt a lot worse than that i
mean really that was the last of the 70s
super bowl smotherings that this most
recent super bowl kind of reminded me of
from super bowl three to four to six
seven eight nine ten and twelve all felt
like smotherings not ten but eleven and
this was the last one when the cowboys
just completely dominated the broncos
offense and picked off craig morton as
many times as he completed passes to the
guys in the orange jerseys yeah that was
certainly an ugly performance uh roger
stallback that was what roger's second
super ball that he got to win there um
so and that that also you know that was
a game where we saw that deep touchdown
pass that roger stall back through where
the receiver kind of fell in the end
zone and lost the ball just as he went
in the end zone where i want to go man
maybe we should replay that game too i'm
not sure he would have caught that ball
in current environment uh i know i'm
just being funny yeah it was but it was
butch johnson and actually
shireen williams and i were talking
about that because she was a big cowboys
fan growing up preston pearson is
actually the guy who threw that pass it
was a gadget play it wasn't starbucks
that's that's right i totally forgot
that that was a gadget play okay so now
man there's some good ones to choose
from here but i think i'm gonna go
somewhere that you know hits home for
you gonna take you back to super bowl
nine oh the minnesota vikings yes this
will have been their third super bowl
loss in five years as a little young
mike florian was going go vikings go
fran tarkinting
um it's tarkinton that's all right so
either way you were young you couldn't
talk that well at that time so i was
just imitating you i was ten i was nine
but fran tarkinton super bowl nine it is
the great steelers steel curtain defense
i get that but 11 for 26 102 yards no
touchdowns three interceptions uh as
you're if you're watching on tv here i
see one of his receivers getting killed
over the middle and the ball popping in
the air but yes that was a rough day at
the office i've only seen highlights of
course it's not like i went back and
watched the game film but i know that he
was running around a lot and throwing
the ball into a lot of coverage uh and
sorry mike uh sorry you had to deal with
that as a young kid
that game was two nothing at the half
and it still is the lowest scoring super
bowl through the first 30 minutes this
year though it was three nothing at the
half and 16 to six was the final 13 to
three this year there there are some and
the vikings would have been shut out
there were several games early on in
super bowl history that would have been
shutouts but for fluky plays seven would
have been a shutout but for that garrow
your premium remember that's that
debacle there right and a block punt by
the vikings in the fourth quarter where
it would have been 16 nothing and they
could have played they could have played
another eight quarters the vikings would
have never gotten anything going
offensively they just didn't have it
as you said in super bowl 53 it wasn't
well no in the it was the the players
not the scheme that was huge guys the
steelers up front could dominate the
vikings defensive line they were small
and fast and against the dolphins in
eight and against the steelers in nine
they just couldn't stop the running game
larry zonka ran all over one year frank
and franco harris the next year all
right uh my last one um boy i hate to do
this because because we we he was on our
set last week he came over and said hi
to us he was nice to us
but he wasn't very nice to eagles fans
during super bowl 15. ron jaworski ah
josh
the guy whose film habits you you try to
mimic and you also mimicked his
quarterback habits at least in this game
three interceptions thrown by ron
jaworski in super bowl 15 all the same
guy and it wasn't a defensive back it
was rod martin west virginia native rod
martin a linebacker
after the first one maybe you don't
throw it in his direction the second one
after two you definitely don't throw the
ball anywhere close to rod martin three
interceptions in what i thought was
going to be a great super bowl but uh
from the moment kenny king took a swing
pass 80 yards right i knew that the
eagles were in for a long day so sorry
jaws but uh you got him there but uh
yeah it didn't happen once they got
there the old polish rifle as they used
to call him jaworski did not have his
best day uh and he i know he had a great
year that year and of course he had a
great career but yeah that is one where
i think he was ron jaworski and he
didn't go and watch that film
because that wasn't fun to watch who
else who else did you have on your list
like i almost went with boomer and
siason and super bowl 23. i thought
about that just because he was the mvp
of football that year
tony almost won the game tony easton was
horrible he's the only starting
quarterback to never complete a pass in
a super bowl yeah that was that was
another one i almost like i did i felt
bad almost about him and carrie collins
just because i felt like their offenses
were so outmatched it like wasn't even
fair uh but anyways i threw my buddy
carrie under the bust regardless
well and and speaking of self-scouting
thyself you know i thought of joe
theismann in super bowl 18 because there
was that play at the end of the half
where jack squirrek read what was coming
because washington had played the
raiders during the regular years and at
the end of the half remember joe
washington wore like actual glasses on
big screen black frames right yeah and
they had the screen right and and and it
popped and they tried it again at the
end of the half same circumstance they
tried the same play jack squirrik saw it
coming that was on the cover of sports
illustrated after that super bowl
squyrick picks it off and that was the
dagger game was over at halftime and
it's all i mean look it's on the play
caller but but back in those days the
quarterback i think had a little more
influence than he does today he wasn't
just a you know a character in the
madden game he actually had more
discretion to exercise theisman should
have known what was happening and he
should have not thrown that pass yeah
that was another one i was thinking of
all right let's recap and take a break
the uh picks from chris sims carrie
collins in super bowl 34 i mean 35 ben
rothenberger and 40 fran target in the
super bowl nine i had rich gannon in 37
craig morton in 12 and jaws ron jaworski
and super bowl fifth pretty sure i won
right
well no no because you got carrie
collins in the wrong super bowl you are
disqualified i win stats what do you
think we gotta go i gotta give it to
mike rich gannon threw three pick sixes
to me that's huge that's staggering
screw you staff all right we'll get out
of here we'll wrap up well i like you
today stat
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports